من الناحية النظرية ، لا يعد لقاح فيروس كورونا
أمرًا صعبًا للغاية ،
وأفضل طريقة لمنع انتشار
عدوى فيروسية هي الحصول على لقاح
يستغرق تطوير لقاح طبيعي عدة
سنوات العلماء في جميع أنحاء العالم
في سباق مع الوقت في محاولة لتطوير
لقاح  نحن نحارب تفشي
الفيروس في الوقت الحالي حيث يستمر فيروس كورونا الجديد
في الانتشار في جميع أنحاء العالم
ويصعد عدد القتلى العلماء في
ألمانيا مثل عدد لا يحصى من الآخرين حول
العالم في سباق مع الوقت في
محاولة لتطوير لقاح بأسرع ما يمكن
لمرض.  العالم العلمي
لديه الكثير لنتعلمه عن عائلة
فيروسات كورونا ليست جديدة ، فقد عرفنا
عنها لفترة طويلة جدًا في الواقع ،
هناك مجموعة منهم كانت
تصيب البشر
لفترة طويلة جدًا وحوالي 10 إلى  30 في المائة من
جميع التهابات الجهاز التنفسي العلوي
سببها فيروسات كورونا للبشر ، إنه
فيروس جديد ولكن عندما تتحدث عن
فيروسات جديدة فهي جديدة على المواصفات البشرية
بسبب معرفتنا
أن الإنسان والجنس البشري لم يصابوا أبدًا
بهذا الفيروس المعين ،
وهذا ما تقصده بكلمة جديد ، إنه
جديد حقًا على الإنسان ، لا يمكن أن يكون الضغط
أعلى مع ارتفاع عدد
حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا الجديد كل يوم والعالم.
الاقتصاد
يتعرض لضربات من فيروسات كورونا آثار الرئيس
ترامب في اجتماع مع صانعي الأدوية
حث الصناعة على
ابتكار لقاح في أسرع وقت ممكن.
قلت:
أسدي معروفاً لي أسرعوا به ،
وأن أفضل طريقة
لمنع انتشار العدوى الفيروسية هي
الحصول على لقاح يبني
المناعة لدى شخص ما بحيث يكون
محميًا من انتشار عدوى
فيروسات كارانو.  تم تسميتها
لأنها تاج به مسامير على السطح ،
وهو بروتين مسنن موجود على
سطح فيروس كورونا وهو ما
يسمح له بالتعلق والدخول
خلايا الجهاز التنفسي هذا
هو بروتين سبايك من سطح
فيروس كورونا ويجلس على
الفيروس مثل هذا ويسمح للفيروس
بالتعلق والدخول إلى الخلايا
لذلك يعتمد مختبرنا على
الإحداثيات ثلاثية الأبعاد  قادرًا
على طباعة نموذج كهذا ، وهذا
يسمح للأشخاص بتصميم ربما أجسامًا مضادة
أو جزيئات صغيرة يمكنها الارتباط في
تجاويف صغيرة ومنع هذا
الجزيء من الارتباط
بغشاء الخلية المضيفة ، وبالتالي يمكن أن يكون ذلك
مفيدًا حقًا لتطوير اللقاح ، فهناك
العديد من المجموعات المختلفة  صنع
اللقاحات وهناك العديد من
الطرائق والطرق المختلفة لصنع اللقاحات ، لكن
جميعها تقريبًا ستحتوي على
الارتفاع بشكل ما أو بطريقة ما
لأننا نريد التحقق من الارتفاع المفاجئ في
شخصين للسماح لجهاز المناعة لدينا برفع
الأجسام المضادة ضده وجعله جاهزًا لذلك.
الهجوم والانقسام
لتعاوننا مع الطبيب بارني جراهام
في مركز أبحاث اللقاحات في
المعاهد الوطنية للصحة ،
قامت مجموعته بإنتاج  ced نفس البنية التي
استخدمناها لتحديد الهيكل
واستخدموا ذلك لتحصين الفئران
والبدء في النظر في الاستجابة المناعية ،
ترى كيف يمكن أن تتحرك هنا ما نعرفه
عن هذا الجزيء هو أنه
لقاح أفضل إذا كان بإمكانك  لتحقيق الاستقرار فيه ،
نعلم أن هذا هو
مجال ربط المستقبلات ونعلم أن هناك
أجسامًا مضادة تجمع بين كل من هذا
الجزء وهذا الجزء مجال ربط المستقبلات
التي يمكنها تحييد الفيروس ، لذلك من
خلال إعطاء الجزيء بأكمله يمكننا
إعطاء الجهاز المناعي أفضل فرصة له
صنع أجسام مضادة تغطي جميع
النقاط المعرضة للخطر على هذا
الفيروس.شركة أمريكية ألمانية تعالج فاك ، والتي
كان رئيسها التنفيذي في البيت الأبيض لمقابلة
الرئيس ترامب ، تصنع اللقاحات من خلال
دمج رمز الفيروس
في الخلايا البشرية لمساعدة الجسم على
حماية نفسه كل من هذه
الأنابيب الصغيرة  يحتوي على بنية مختلفة من
رمز الفيروس في الوقت الحالي
، يحاول العلماء في المختبر الرئيسي في ألمانيا معرفة أيهما
أكثر أمانًا  والأكثر فاعلية أن يتم تحويله
إلى لقاح بينما لا يرغبون
في تحديد موعد له ، لكنهم يعتقدون
أنهم يقتربون من ذلك ، فنحن
نستعد لتجربة إكلينيكية من
بين التركيبات المختلفة التي يتعين علينا
إدخال أفضلها فيها  العيادات التي
نجريها في مناقشات مستمرة مع
السلطات التنظيمية بينما يقر مسؤولو الصحة في الولايات المتحدة
بأن الأمر سيستغرق
عامًا على الأقل قبل أن يتم
اعتماد أحدهم ، وتقول الشركة إنها تعمل
وقتًا إضافيًا لإنجازها قريبًا [موسيقى] إذا قارنت تطوير لقاح طبيعي يستغرق  منذ عدة سنوات
نكافح تفشي المرض في الوقت الحالي ،
وبالتالي فإن السلطات التنظيمية تعمل
وتحاول القيام بذلك في غضون
عام واحد ، لذا من أجل تطوير لقاح طبيعي ،
ستستغرق العملية بأكملها
في غضون 10 إلى 20 عامًا
لتنفيذ جميع الخطوات المختلفة التي
العمل مع البشر مكلف للغاية ،
فنحن نحاول القيام بذلك
بأسرع ما يمكن ، وربما يكون أفضل سيناريو للتفاؤل
هو عام أكثر
واقعية في  من 18 إلى 24
شهرًا ، يجب أن تكون المرحلة الأولى في
غضون أسابيع ، وهذا أمر مثير
حقًا لأننا بعد شهرين أو ثلاثة أشهر فقط
من أول اكتشاف
للفيروس ، وبدأنا في التسجيل في
المرحلة الأولى من التجربة السريرية.  التي تم إجراؤها في
غضون عام تقريبًا غير مسموع
فيما يتعلق بشهادة الأدوية ،
لكن العاملين في الشركة
يخبروننا أنهم لم يروا أبدًا
هذا القدر من الإلحاح الدولي
من جانب الحكومات من جانب
المنظمات غير الحكومية وأيضًا  بالطبع من جانب
شركات الأدوية والمختبرات لمحاولة الحصول على
لقاح في السوق بأسرع وقت
ممكن وآمن قدر الإمكان ، أعتقد
أنه من المهم أن أقول إنه كلما
طورت لقاحًا ، لا يوجد
شيء مثل شيء مؤكد  من
الناحية النظرية ، لا يعد لقاح فيروس كورونا
أمرًا صعبًا للغاية كما هو الحال مع أي
تطوير لقاح ، فهناك دائمًا
عقبات غير متوقعة
ولكن لدي تفاؤل حذر
بأننا سنكون قادرين على تطوير لقاح مرة أخرى
t هذا و فيروسات التاجية الأخرى
[موسيقى]